New York Times has struck a different
tone on relations with Russia in a piece
by the papers editorial board it
suggests that America should improve
ties with Moscow to counter the growing
influence of China China not Russia
represents by far the greater challenge
to American objectives over the long
term that means President Trump is
correct to try to establish a sound a
relationship with Russia and peel it
away from China the article which echoes
the conclusions of a recent Pentagon
white paper highlights space and the
Arctic as to possible areas for greater
cooperation between the US and Russia
the authors also write that
re-establishing dialogue and arms
control could help the two rivals to
ramp up bilateral ties when the peace
does come as a departure from previous
New York Times articles that have taken
a far more hostile stance towards Russia
in the past for instance the paper has
castigated Donald Trump for not being
tough enough on Vladimir Putin
particularly in the wake of their
Helsinki summit last year there has been
no sign that the United States has
derived any benefit from mr. Trump's
obsequious towards mr. Putin though mr.
Trump himself has now at least gotten a
shiny new soccer ball it remains a
mystery why the president unlike any of
his Republican or Democratic
predecessors is unwilling to call out
put him next to mr. Putin and other
dictators and he turns to putty the New
York Times is worried
it's very worried about any kind of a
taunt and kind of Alliance being
developed by by China and Russia and so
their forwards are concerned and maybe
it's gone too far
it's trying to convey that uh that it's
calling for a course correction maybe
it's time to to lower down the
anti-russian hostilities and to behave a
little less aggressively aggressively
towards China but the you know the u.s.
thinks of itself as a global Empire but
it really can't control the entire world
and to countries that are outside the
the imperial consensus are China and
Russia so not very surprisingly given
the
America is increasingly unilateral
approach to all the world affairs their
funding they have a good deal in common
with one another and therefore they're
exploring ways of cooperating and and
cooperating against a growing us threat
a growing growing us new lateral ism
arbitrariness aggressive behavior etc
you